Nothing motivates me aside to meeting a sleeping.
I lie in my bed all day.
No one of my computer,
not on my phone,
not doing anything.
I just lie there thinking what's happening to me.
I would say that you are,
this is not a diagnostic comment and I don't know enough about you to provide
that sort of information,
but I would recommend that you see a therapist and be screened for depression
because that's what it looks like to me.
And I would say that if it's depression,
you should do something about it because depression is very hard on people.
If produces a lot of stress hormones like cortisol and that can hurt you,
may,
you know it's,
it's only been a couple of days,
I wouldn't worry about it.
But if it's a chronic powder then you should go talk to somebody.
Even your family doctor,
you know,
and there's always the possibility that a low dose of an antidepressant might be
worth trying.
You'd know in a month if it fixed you.
But I would say don't,
don't stay in that situation now.
Go,
go find out,
do whatever you have to do.
To get out of it.
And especially the fact that you're not on your computer,
not on your phone,
not doing anything.
You know,
you're,
you're ruminating that's just lying there thinking about Snoop's of negative
emotion.
And you don't have any positive emotion,
you know,
that's why you're not on your computer or your phone.
And so one of the characteristics of depression,
while I suppose two of the characteristics is a decrease in positive motivation.
And so that means that you're not interested in anything and an increase in
negative emotion.
And that can manifest itself in that.
I'm just lying there thinking,
you know,
so,
um,
go talk to someone,
tell someone that this is happening.
Get to your family doctor,
let them know what's happening.
Get them to give you a depression screening and uh,
and see what you can do about it.
Because there are effective treatments for depression and sometimes
antidepressants work like a absolute charm.